I have to get to the truth
of what happened that night.
I am for truth, no matter who tells it.
I'm for justice,
no matter who it's for or against.
Eighteen years, ten months, 24 days.
That's how long Warren Cave
has sat in prison
for the murder of Chuck Buhrman.
I helped seal Warren's fate
with a series of articles.
But is there an innocent man in prison...
and did I lead that charge?
You portrayed me
as a privileged psychopath.
Now I live in a house
full of men who breathe to lie...
and I could smell yours
before you even started talking.
How could a mother and two daughters
sleep through such a violent encounter?
And they never recovered
the murder weapon.
-What are you hiding?
-You leave it.
Or I can make your life miserable in here.
There's a monster inside every one of us.
You terrify me.
What about you? What's in there?
You're playing with people's lives.
Are you ready for the consequences?
You think all the secrets
came out during the trial?
-You tell Parnell to back away.
-You messed with her family.
You have no idea
what I've done for my daughters.
Families... they take care of each other.
I have to get to the truth
of what happened that night.
The people will get their show.